hey what's up and welcome to the lobby
game spots weekly hangout every tuesday
2 p.m right here on videogames.com my
name is daniel dawari joined by chris
waters hey dan benito gonzalez we got a
packed show today we got star of ign and
youtube mr greg miller graham over
greggy in the house he's going to come
on play some ghostbusters
on a really old sega system because it's
video game history month right here on
thevideogames.com also wolfenstein order
we're playing the game and giving away
that ridiculous special edition that
doesn't actually have the game in it so
we're also giving away the game great
work bethesda's whoever came up with
that idea we're sorting you out don't
worry about it we got your back we got
it we figured it out we figured it out
all you got to do is put the game in the
thing yeah yeah it's done
get in the box does it fit the box
probably not duct tape i'm not going to
open the box slap
but first of all
let's get right into this i believe
titanfall has a bunch of new dlc
expeditions finally come out three new
maps and some other nonsense uh in the
dlc proper is the three new maps but uh
it came along with a patch that has
updated a bunch of stuff in turn their
their tweaks with gameplay and also with
uh sort of the menu system and how you
get into that stuff depending on what
platform you're on as well as bonito
knows well yes benito gonzalez you've
been playing this on pc and i believe
you're not very happy not happy with
some of the the updates that this patch
has kicked not happy at all like okay so
this came out with the 20th right was it
the 15th the 15th it came out last
thursday and like it came out that day
and they released the patch notes the
day before it and there were stuff there
was stuff first of all in the patch
notes that that weren't in the patch
nuts okay we're in the game i went into
the patch notes a major thing for
example being that in capture the flag
you used to be able to grab flag hop in
your titan dash dash dash
known as titan capping yeah yeah you
can't bring the flag into your titan
anymore nor if a flag is on the ground
can you walk over it with your titan to
return it like titans and flags are now
oil and water and this is kind of
something that the community wanted like
everyone thought it was super cheap that
you can get in there titan just right
like was it like unreal tournaments or
any of those games whenever you did ctf
you couldn't go near yeah well then you
might have used vehicles well like
ut3 there were the other ones you could
use that weird skateboard they gave you
the hoverboard but you weren't telling
you yeah yeah so like people were happy
we're like everyone was stoked right but
and then the day after that on pc at
least this isn't true for uh xbox one pc
they removed ctf and pilot hunter as
modes
they're just gone they removed them from
the match from the matchmaking mode so
like you can still get at those modes
but you have to play variety packs
variety pack or private lobby you can't
choose to go i want to play a ctf game
i'm going to play a ctf game matchmaking
wise and if you look at my if you look
at my overview like i have like 85 ctf
because that's kind of all they played
out
yeah i'm all ctf after the first like
week just like leveling up and stuff i
was just playing ctf and i was super
psyched about the patch right about new
maps i was like [ __ ] yeah new maps yeah
the new maps so the new maps have their
own lobbies like uh and we're actually
getting into a match right now in uh war
games this is a cool map too
but uh
the maps are the lobbies are variety
pack there's an attrition there's
there's an attrition uh
sorry
lobby on xbox one as well but uh yeah
you gotta that's how you get into it and
so it begs the question why did they
remove it yeah it's gotta be a player
popular well they uh they said something
in uh on their forums i think last week
and they said it was something about
server populations that yeah pilot
hunter and ctf weren't popular modes so
i guess to take that population out of
there and put them into
you know your variety pack or yeah
attrition or whatever it seems like
they're like to me like i stopped yeah i
stopped playing titanfall because i
couldn't that sounds like they're
ruining some users experiences to make
their
matchmaking stuff work better but i feel
like that problem is on them and not on
people who bought the game yeah totally
like especially
when you're used to it there are better
yeah like especially on the pc when
you're used to like at least server
browsers or like there is like a yeah
there's no server browser on pc and i
think that was the biggest shock for
bonito he's telling me about this i'm
like yeah man this is just like you know
that's how it goes on consoles you don't
uh you know you're beholden to what
matchmaking playlist you you have
uh but that's not the case on pc not
anymore titanfall it is all right so
this is war games this is one of the
three new maps um just mopping up some
grunts and as you saw there they didn't
actually die in bloody spatters they
like disappeared like they de-rez
basically oh so this is uh this is
actually not this is a a training
grounds type map watch it you can see
this looks like the tutorial basically
the pilots disappear too in between
parts yeah the pilots disappear as well
uh so all this but it's also sort of
blended with you know the this realistic
stuff so
it all takes place in your mind and mac
is saying in my ear that is a tron
simulator it's a tron simulator yeah
there's no bicycle light cycles
unfortunately uh that there's no other
vehicles besides
leticons i'd like for them to lean into
this a little bit more absolutely parts
of this map like lots of parts of this
map are in like other maps right oh
really like sections of this map are
parts of other maps okay yeah so like
this part looks to me like one of the
like the hallways from rise uh
for example but i'm not sure if that's
actually true uh because a lot of this
sort of like
industrial rusty frontier that sign
thing is called this sign yeah right in
angel city
um so it's sort of a mishmash and it
allows
you to did they use all the stuff they
made already and make a map out of all
the stuff well the story the story is
that this was a dev map okay this is the
map that you're developing maps on right
they didn't put it in the final game
well that's the story you'll see i don't
know if it's because i'm already
thinking there's only three maps in this
dlc and now this one seems to be 50 made
up this one's already played it's like a
great like clip show map
equivalent of a map can we get vince
back on the show please i got some
questions to ask him
um if you have any questions actually
yourself and you're watching the show uh
by all means send them in via the usual
methods send them the twitch chat
gamespot comments or at gamespot on the
twitters
my kick my leg is not long enough
anymore you know when i was talking
earlier i feel like you should have a
dolce burn card that like gives you an
extra long look on your leg on your kick
that'd be great that would be hilarious
uh no new burn cards um
just new maps
the other other some other tweaks in the
um
the most recent patch which you get i
mean you get that for free that stuff is
not
uh behind the 9.99 you got to pay for
this map pack and season passes 20 40
25. 25. okay how many dlc packs are
gonna be it's 24.99 for three planned
dlc okay
have they alluded to having
something a bit more substantial like
having titans or burn cards or anything
that isn't just straight up maps i
haven't heard but i hope so
you know what i'm not really sure if
they have probably not more titans maybe
guns i'm guessing the problem with that
is
you know you're just sort of creating
further segmentation in terms of your
player population like you can't you
can't have certain oh it's just jump
front that's pretty good
not attempt to do all right i see you
pilot
um but it might not be it might just be
a patch like that like big stuff yeah it
should be at least just for everyone
yeah
yeah you're wondering those situations
who's like we asked vince on the show if
they were beholden to ea to ensure that
they had some sort of uh
dlc pack and he said that they weren't
that this was something they wanted to
do which you know it's a multi-player
shooter it makes sense to want to you
know
freshen up give your give people some uh
no it makes sense to let the community
make maps that's the thing i'm like when
this tournament news came out again last
week
it was like especially when there's a pc
version of a game it's
not hard yeah all the best maps
eventually come from the community and
like not to be super adoptive about how
games are made but this is using the
source engine so yeah like
i'm not saying no move like i'd like to
see dust in titanfall
yes
can you imagine
great two-fourths
okay this actually sounds like a really
bad two four would be awesome
he's so bad can i play portal 2 as a
titan please
i think aztec might be fa aztec would be
fun yeah
what's your favorite in the twitch show
what's your favorite counter-strike map
you aren't realized in titanfall mine is
compound
scouts knives
you're my
uh so when is the was there a delay on
this or something did it get bumped back
a week uh they never announced a week
okay for it to come out so
it just kind of came out it's not out
for xbox 360 yet right
okay in keeping with did you just did
you just satchel yourself i think
technically i did not satchel myself
this guy killed me before i could
satchel myself thus shaving me saving me
that ultimate indignity not that much
not that much of a save that was pretty
bad
oh that's how they said when the next uh
dlc is likely to come in no
they didn't announce the date for this
one until the week it came out dude
they're not gonna announce it and they
won't even tell us what was in it yeah
so there's two other maps uh this match
is not going well for my team i should
probably turn to
that dude please kill that dude
how much how much do you think so nicely
how much legs do you think titanfall has
in relation to like its core popularity
because we've got e3 coming up we're
gonna hear about the new call of duty
there's gonna be watchdogs coming out
wolfy times okay that doesn't
multiplayer but like we're out at the
sort of the the q1 uh death period
do you think titanfall have you seen
like a drop in the amount of people
playing at all on pc i sure have yeah it
seems like there definitely has been on
pc especially to do you know to
necessitate the kind of thing that
benito's talk was complaining about the
the matchmaking change that's gonna just
mess you up
uh i would say that yeah the player
population is probably gonna is you know
has you know hopefully seen a resurgence
because of this
uh but it's that you know this is
not like a whole lot going on in terms
of other
you know modes and stuff to get to yeah
i personally is your queue time on xbox
one is it fine it's yeah it's very good
uh i want server population numbers for
pc that's what i want to see yeah i want
to see like what what are the numbers if
it booted through steam you'd be able to
see that probably as well
um
is there a way of like picking your map
in the in the matchmaking it's not is
there no only private private lobby
actually the only way to really do that
is to play campaign mode right oh yeah
but no one plays campaign mode anymore
do you think folks are doing private
lobby stuff because would it be
interesting they definitely are like i'm
actually a part of the the reddit
community the top pc nashville shout out
to mashie
and uh they do like friday private
private lobby games stuff like that so
it exists but it's not super it's not
huge yet yeah yeah not a pc community
you just wonder with the more maps they
release then the more picky people are
going to come which might push more
people towards private servers and then
exacerbate the problem they're having
with folks it's like there's no way
there's no way to like browse private
servers though you have to know it from
some outside spot right you can't
there's no way from within titanfall to
find private gear okay oh so are you
just friend jumping into friends games
or like forums or you need to know who
you're getting into a match with all
right so this match is concluding what i
think we'll do is uh try to escape
and then um
start another match we can get a glimpse
at one of the other maps cool yeah yeah
just a it'd be good to have a look at
one of them
is there are there um matchmaking for
just the new pack is there a dlc only
option okay do they have that for
domination xbox one oh no what i run
right at the cluster missile is it just
attrition
there is expedition variety pack and
expedition attrition
on xbox one matchmaking in addition to
the five core modes or in addition to
attrition hardpoint ctf pilot hunter
variety pack which won't i don't think
they will bring in attrition maps that's
a great strategy do the old cluster
missile right by the entrance to the
drop ship
your bones yeah
yeah so some of the other tweaks they
did with the patch we talked about this
during the live stream last week but
like
you know stuff like uh an auto titan's
not going to enter
the protective dome of another of an
enemy titan and kill itself you know uh
what else there's also like little
tweaks nuclear ejection is a little bit
more deadly to titan yes the crater has
like i think it's more powerful and they
made it how could it be more powerful to
kill someone in one hit they made the
amp crater do more damage to titans oh
oh interesting if you can chip away and
tighten a little bit usually sort of
post release tweaks yeah
and yeah what would you like to see in a
burn card
yeah i think you burned casper
dawson well so what a water broker like
you know you've got the amped weapons uh
so there's no there's no new one of
those without a new burn card uh
the sort of ones that affect all those
are this tied pretty much to perks
though these are tied to your tactical
abilities i've never gotten that one
before i'd run it so it's permanently
stemmed okay always stim there's longer
cloak there's longer activities have you
ever called something else before
maybe that's why i mean there's smuggled
there's prosthetics so what's the
difference between that and generally
this replaces your ability with a longer
stim this is always stemmed wait what's
the difference between that one and the
faster one the other one that one this
is just your you move faster so the
adrenaline's faster than prosthetic legs
i don't know man i'm not scientist
unclear
get on it reality check i would guess
that prosthetic legs faster movement
speed is not quite as fast as stim speed
but stim isn't just speed it's also
health regeneration that's right
and that
sound effect when you're running i just
do that with that isn't that just when
you're damaged isn't it
titanfall sound effects
all right so swampland this is the one
that i feel like you've seen you see the
most of
it it looks really cool it plays well
you can make all sorts of star wars
references why are the wookies uh
exactly so you're gonna go for the cash
no he's going for the kashyyyk reference
which i respect because it's you know
planted with a lot of tall trees i don't
think he would i don't know if he
knowingly having a clue i don't think he
knows darth maul gonna turn up
yup use the phone
yeah it's darth maul burn card you're a
wizard howard you can pick it up
pop culture literate daniel dwyer
gotta love him uh so this has like
it's got like a
sort of a modern industrial facility in
one corner this old temple area and
another which you might recognize from
like lagoon it's that kind of it's that
style
um
nestled in muir woods
yeah nestled in your woods which
basically yeah so there are these trees
and you can like zip line up into the
canopy or you can ride on these um you
can run along sort of broke down trees
that serve as ramps i feel like these
got these things yeah so this is one of
the remember those pictures that leaked
before titanfall came out where people
were talking about the creatures for a
while
yeah i'm pretty sure this is the area
that that was uh
showing off this one and like run up a
big mossy tree you can get really high
up into the trees too you get really
high mushrooms as well
are you able to effectively run hide
over here on this tree like wall jump
from tree to tree it depends on the tree
that you're in
oh where did that guy go can be done
there's one more over here it's not
super cool on last night's standing
actually it's great in titans and i'll
show you why when i get to titan a
little bit just because it's uh the
trees are pretty thick at their bases
but they're also
um
slippery and wet i like it
yeah that's exactly what i was gonna say
danny
nailed it
all right we're gonna get a couple more
kills here we're gonna call it a day i
want to see you smoke oh well that's
that
chris waters thank you very
yeah there's one over there here i'll
try to tree run over there to it yup
join us next week on the last vicious
beginning when we play all of when
you're still playing titanfall counter
strike hits in titanfall go up on a tree
trees office
here we go here's the office would be
good with titans
like they have the one spot outside
where they cannot like all 12 times are
gonna be right outside the parking lot
great no
i was not saying no to you you can throw
you can toss to whatever you want don't
worry about it i was yelling at trees
that is titanfall from respawn
entertainment coming soon to an xbox one
that's expedition to dlc your energy is
incredible one you are really nailing it
get that season pass if you want to play
three new maps one of which you've
already played a bunch of all right
we're gonna talk
technically you know i don't want to be
super adopted by titanfall i love that
game but come on we can do better than
this uh all right we're back pretty soon
justin haywald's gonna be on the couch
to talk about all this uh twitch youtube
google uh craziness but first a game
that came out uh today but we actually
played on last week's show transistor uh
launch traders just come out for it so
as soon as we're not playing it today
we said we'd uh show the trailer first
of all though i don't think we have a
box of it
i totally forgot giveaway there it is
panzerhunt look at that thing that is
the best special edition without a game
i've seen he seems to be missing from
that picture danny it looks cool it's
got bad is it a sweet robo dog statue
is it uh some awesome like journals that
probably have some uh nazi information
no oh is it some pictures like concept
art pictures
they got loads of those crap what is it
so we're gonna give you the game on
whatever platform you want
uh bs uh i guess
uh pc xbox one ps4 is that long that's
it is it on password all right um so
make sure you follow us at uh gamespot
tweet us use the hashtag gs the lobby
and uh put in your platform of choice
make sure you're following us though so
we can email you or message you back and
get your address and stuff now i think
we're about ready to see transistor
let's do it
i always thought
it's hard to make new friends
but making enemies
i guess that's easy
we got four problems
we saw their faces
we know their names
know what they're capable of
they'll find us again
they'll find you and finish the job
unless you find them first
you always have a plan
and now
you have something more
here from supergiant games creators of
bastion of course we had greg casavan on
the show last week so once this show is
over feel free to go back and watch that
on demand 8.0 gamespot.com indeed have
you played so good oh so beautiful so i
love the the combat is very tactical in
a very satisfying way and also there's a
dedicated button for you to hum along
with whatever music is playing at any
time which is just magical it's great i
like bastion but i i'm not a fan of that
type of genre but like whenever like the
new diablo came out or stuff like that
it's like i play for a little bit and
then i sort of i mean like the
third-person rpg that isometric rpg or
like even the combat in that way i don't
know maybe i'm like i'm covering a lot
of different types of games in one cloth
but for whatever reason bathroom was one
i never really got like super engaged
with but i absolutely adore this and i
think the art style in the music goes a
long way but the combat's brilliant yeah
and the when you die the way you just
lose one of your powers and it just sets
you back in like it's clever ass game
yes and the story seems to be really
good really clever but uh enough between
sister justin haywald you're here which
means some goddamn stuff happens
somewhere in the video games industry
not a lot is happening
it's a slow news week as we
look as we come into e3 i mean there's
there's not a lot of big news that's
going to be coming up because everyone
has all of these stories that they're
keeping bottled up because if they get
out then those people are going to get
fired last week microsoft did a real bad
job of that and they just decided to
talk a whole bunch of mess about halo i
guess what happened yeah yeah i mean
sometimes you do get those leaks that
come out and then everybody just talks
about all of this you're like well we
were gonna save this but we might as
well just come out with it now right all
right i i don't think all everything is
always confirmed sometimes story details
or something interesting leaks out there
was a watch uh far cry 4 story details
came out just recently um you know the
page was leaked out so you can read
about what the story is going to be but
that's not official yet even though it
was on the uplay page yeah
so but outside of that we did hear some
interesting stuff this weekend where
google isn't told not google youtube is
in talks to buy twitch you know twitch
is the popular game streaming service
that we use here that we're on right now
hi twix
what's going on this is where you go for
games to to watch stuff about games and
it's not google that's buying them i
mean google owns youtube but youtube is
the one buying them
and that's interesting in in both
positive and negative ways i mean and
it's good that they are still a startup
they are not a huge company that just
has lots of money to throw at something
like their twitch programming there are
problems with twitch it's not the
perfect program there are things that
could be done to make it better yeah
it's not a great experience in every way
you're saying that there could be a
benefit to it because it's a big company
and they can add you know
infrastructure-wise or like content-wise
might be able to improve what's already
there yeah i mean they can expand and
offer features that the community has
been demanding that that we would like
to see in a system like this
on the flip side it's youtube um you
know youtube does a lot of interesting
things i go to youtube for all of my
game trailers and that kind of stuff
when i'm not looking at them on game
spot of course yeah nice work saved it
but youtube has gotten into a little bit
of trouble with community for you know
copyright infringement and being really
really quick to just bring the hammer
down on people that are going against
what some of their media partners are
doing and we had all that nintendo stuff
that happened a couple of months ago
when that was all getting pulled they
also do a lot more stuff like cont uh
region locking of content
uh or just like cutting out the audio on
a video if it if it goes against some
copyright or a possible copyright it
doesn't even have to necessarily
infringe on a copyright if someone just
reports it they can just cut out the
audio and you just have a kind of
useless video and twitch isn't like the
wild west but there's definitely streams
you watch on it where people are like
just just having fun just playing their
own music just showing you know content
that might necessarily be theirs and
then also i feel like with the sort of
the continuing conversation about who
owns
gameplay footage with the yes play stuff
and all these youtubers getting you know
their their job essentially is based on
showing off
fold on some of that gameplay google do
then everything falls on it you know we
really hope that you know youtube has
learned their lesson from introducing
that real id stuff that they did that
when google came in and they said well
this is going to be linked to your
google plus account you're going to use
this real name you're going to have to
sign into google plus and everybody hate
it i mean that's a terrible system that
didn't work right and it's still kind of
wonky
and i'm sure that if they bought out
twitch if this merger does go through
yeah
speculations is there all wow it's it
isn't they're in talks yeah but it's not
it is definitely not set in stone it's
not necessarily going to happen a lot of
things could step in the way in the
meantime but i don't think that they
would come in and just immediately
integrate that that same real name id
system that would just be complete
stupidity and it would
it would make a lot of people really
unhappy it was especially for streamers
i feel like the anonymity thing is an
important part of that for some anyway
and twitch is such a community driven
thing it's so much about the people
being invested in the people who are
there and the games that are being
played and the the chat community that
they're in that you know you gotta be
really careful to not destabilize any of
the pillars of that community to to not
shake that up because then
what what if you bought and then just
totally soured so i'm sure that's on
their radar is like we gotta we gotta
treat this with white gloves and the
other scary thing is just that youtube
is such a big behemoth of a creature and
i basically see all of my video on
either youtube or twitch and if twitch
buys or youtube by twitch then basically
i'm seeing all of that owned by google
now i'm not going to other places to
watch video and then so if they do
something stupid like introducing that
real id system that's going to affect
everything that i watch there's not
really an alternative that i can go to
all the eggs are in one basket it's
going to violate all the anti-trust laws
you've set up in your living room to
make sure that not one source has a
dominant view of or you know channel to
your mind share well i mean it's at
least two-thirds because they don't
control my porn at least still
thanks not yet
browsers.com
is next on youtube's list of
acquisitions we got porn i'm sorry and
then google knows everything that i do
sorry the hand motion is not meant to be
that
browser
yep that's better yep oh you're getting
better with each one
you can make a hand motion without it
being something filthy just sit on your
hands no that's still something
oh god
oh god justin haywald uh thank you very
much for coming on thanks for having me
stick around for a second because mary
kish talking about news if you take the
s off that words and then add another
word on to the end of us and you might
come up with
new releases what's up mary that is the
worst segue ever dan yeah those puzzles
are great you think i can't get worse
every week i'll show you i'm not gonna
say that
what's up guys hey barry and we have so
many badass ladies coming in games like
so many good lead lady characters right
child of light yeah ellie was coming
back for the dlc the last of us and now
red yeah i don't forget that nazi dog
well see oh are you going
it could be a girl dog no those are
girls we got girls with their girl games
and then we have boys doing what boys do
and just killing nazis on robot dogs
heteronormativity
everybody wins so let's roll that
beautiful bean footage that really good
wasp yes that's what we say in america
it's a commercial reference okay
so i got a different record for my
references
danny rubenstein came out on old and new
jen
just next gen well it's 360 and ps3
events pretty sure it's not pc
it is okay i'll defer to you it does say
new releases near you it does uh then
tropico five what would you do if you
were presidente el presidente danny i
killed all the nazis oh my god
what makes you think with a tornado i
don't know just you gotta kill some just
to make sure is that woman having her
face tracking guard three she has a
flower she's got some affection in her
face and it makes flowers grow out of
her eye right it's like the last of us
um it's coming out on ps3 hopefully if
she makes it we'll never know though you
could play uh
she rides dragons she's kind of a dragon
whisperer great so you can ride them
they bite people it's pretty cool but
she does have her eyes creeping me right
out
and then the incredible adventures of
van helsing dos oh it's the second one
that's right he had so many adventures
in fact that it required a sequel i
heard that first game was okay maybe you
wouldn't think that you could have that
many incredible adventures but you're
wrong you can
that uh 22nd for that one
here we go transition finally transistor
so ps4 and pc and that is also today it
got an eight out of ten people really
like it yeah it's something else yeah i
cut the video review it's awesome i
really enjoyed it uh and for anyone who
hasn't seen it i didn't put in any
spoilers you didn't i put in anything
that you might have seen during
basically packs did you did you uh i
didn't want it because i want to play it
and you get it
looking through the footage i no i
avoided it so i only did like the first
two hours of gameplay nice work so the
video might have suffered yeah but i
will enjoy
that game without any spoilers so if
you're worried about it i've always
appreciated when video game websites
ensure that there is no spoilers on the
tops of videos i still put the spoiler
warning in there but rest assured i have
no idea what the ending looks like so if
i don't you won't from watching the
review probably really good and you
missed out in some sick footage nice
work all right i'll play it and find out
and that's what you guys should do too
that's it thanks barry bye guys you're
back all right we're gonna shoot off in
a second to see check out some of our uh
live shows and we'll be back in just
over a minute with the one and only mr
greg miller we're gonna play some old
video games stick around
hyper soul
i'll chuck a jar at a child's face it's
a child hit it with jars eat jars [ __ ]
get down with too bad
is this child services this is going
better than i ever could have hoped
it's this one this one don't go
immediately don't go immediately you
have to wait for them
attack and then rewind and then you
don't even know you do the whippy thing
where the whip goes all over the place
oh gross the face is still nice though
oh never mind
what do you remember
oh my gosh yesterday torture chamber
with peter brown as you can see he was
tortured by mr mcbargains there uh
multiple players of course yesterday
sean method this morning the lobby's on
right now uh tomorrow on random
encounter i forget what i'm playing but
i'm pretty sure it's not what's written
there watch dogs on oh we're there
talking about that great
wednesday watch dogs
check that out 9am we're streaming
watchdogs yeah special stream sweet
sorry i believe that's on thursday not
wednesday so the graphic this came in so
late that the graphics team just threw
it together willy nilly who gives
wolfenstein will be on wednesday yep at
two yep so there you go perfect diagram
you can print that out on your put it on
your wall
by it bad information about what's on
when when do you roll the beautiful bean
footage
did you go to the same place with that
no i knew what it was it did see bush's
baked beans they had this talking dog he
knew the family recipe we all they knew
the family wouldn't ruin it yeah but
this god damn dog nobody knew what he
was gonna do what are you gonna do
he was offering to sell it all the time
he's a crazy dog he's probably oh he's
probably dead yeah yeah hi jen's greg
miller hey dude how are you doing thanks
very much coming on oh yeah
the couch is better this house is way
better and this is what it's all about
it's a video game history month yeah and
uh we thought what better uh excuse to
get you in here you're just down the
road hi jen right down the road four
blocks second in brandon right in front
of merrigan's sub shop
are you in their pocket
i'm trying to be cause i'm not going as
well as i want i come in sometimes
they're like oh hey greg and i'm like i
want the free sandwich don't know my
name that's not good enough that was
worth about two weeks i think i better
be come on i'm trying here no mayo i'm
not there no mayo come on you gotta do
something special for that yeah exactly
that tattoo yeah anti-mayo crowd over
here yeah
all right that's
demonstrably false before we tell before
we play this wonderful game that you've
brought in sure uh i want to talk to you
about some video game stuff oh good
that's what i do for a living it is i've
heard that it's not just what you do you
also review oreos on youtube yeah sure
podcast about regular nerd culture right
stuff right i believe you also but ign
signs the checks and that's where i talk
about games what are we talking about e3
oh my goodness what are you excited for
we're like it to be over no
i'm excited to go there and find out new
stuff stuff we don't know about right
that's the big thing like right now it's
like okay cool like
it's you look down the line like we have
these new next-gen systems and
everything's cool and super hd and wow
there's batman coming and one day we'll
have the order
and it's like okay but like
what what is really happening right now
you know what i mean transistor is
awesome and i love having that it's
really cool that the last of us is
coming to ps4 but what's like the big
announcement when the lights go out for
the xbox conference and they come up
what are they going to show on the
screen stuff like that what have you
been playing so far edited two new
consoles like mostly a lot of mario golf
a lot of mario golf world tour i mean 80
hours in right now
i'm over 80 hours now for sure more than
80 hours sunk into mario golf world tour
it's really good if you like mario golf
i think i've played one mario golf yeah
for fans of mario golf for fans we were
waiting on the curve here with the mario
golf fans we were talking about great
mario sports games right here uh did you
play mario strikers in charge a little
bit i didn't get into it like other
people sorry i got 80 errors in that bad
boy see that's pretty good that's that's
cause you're from across the pond that's
very true that's a big deal over there
all right soccer yeah he's like our he's
like our face of of soccer in a in
europe really yeah but he's italian yeah
okay um what have i been playing a lot
on the new systems yes
i played a lot of titanfall i put in 30
hours of titanfall i haven't touched the
new maps yet they look cool i'm excited
for what i saw there of course dc
universe online the best mmo of all time
i put in another
couple with a dozen hours there uh
recently though i started wolfenstein
last night excited to get deeper in that
i like transistor a lot big fans so
beautiful yeah it's gorgeous beautiful i
don't know how they do it i don't know
how many people making these games that
are so beautiful and sounds so good it's
gorgeous yeah
yeah they're just based on the road as
well yeah it's all here we're in the
hotbed of the video game community i
like it yeah uh you talked about a
nintendo game there what do you think
about nintendo going into e3 because
more and more of the conversations seem
to be we're talking
microsoft sony right and nintendo's
some people have written off the new
console completely sure people were
saying concentrate on 3ds stuff how do
you feel about where nintendo are at the
moment i mean i feel like they're
exactly where nintendo always is there's
nothing you know i mean they've been
telling the same story forever and we
always think it's gonna change and like
the wii was the big one right that
caught fire so it looked like it was
different but in reality it was the same
thing of third parties not really
supporting this thing with things that
the core gamer wants but i own my
nintendo for the exclusives right i own
it for the zelda i own it for the mario
golf as you know and i know mario's and
some other things here but no i i mean
coming out of e3 or coming into e3 i
should say with nintendo this year it's
like what are you going to show me what
do you what what what do you got the
zelda would be the next one right kids
love this
they can't wait another year to show us
how we use zelda yeah we got to see what
this final the final hd fully from the
ground up
none of this that tech demo nonsense
yeah exactly yeah and come out with a
win so if nintendo came out and showed a
bunch of really good first party stuff
and there wasn't that much third party
support you'd be
you're kind of cool with that spoiler
alert that's what's gonna happen okay
that is you just saw did they show you
the nintendo directs early because yeah
that's exactly what's gonna happen i
mean i you know i have the wii u mainly
for smash most importantly for cart so
i've got what i want out of that system
i didn't buy it with the thing of like
well here's my definitive assassin's
creed machine all right here's where i'm
only going to play my batman i'm gonna
get my second screen watchdog
so yeah i expect them to come out and do
what they always do show some cute games
that are going to be cool cool well
enough about
new concepts i hate this new crap let's
talk about classic consoles classic
games this is actually jeff gerstmann's
machine jeff gerson's
the sega master system you might have
heard of it it is the def sorry about
that that's all right that's i think
show that controller oh look at this
look at that thing
thanks for dropping that off d-pad
one button and the two button of course
because one button doubles as a start
button a a b that was stolen we couldn't
you couldn't do that you can't do that
so yeah you asked me to come in i did i
asked you to come in and i asked you to
bring a game that was important to you
in your childhood right the game that
like got you passionate about video
games of course so so of course i
brought in a sega master system let's
take a kid i brought in ghostbusters huh
look at that one ghostbusters everybody
mega carter the mega cartridge now
it's great because on the back there's
just a completely bat crap insane
description of ghostbusters oh yeah that
makes little notes
so if you're tired of your regular old
job why not sign it as a ghostbuster and
find out what a real job is
they even say anything about being a
scientist busta makes me feel good no
literally somebody was just like giving
the the spec script for what
ghostbusters was like well i'll just
write the stupid thing about it a real
job not like being a teacher yeah
whatever you're sick of your old job
also here's
my one that and best of all if you're
lucky you'll meet face to face with the
ghost leader of the universe gorza
i hope i hope i hope
not ghosters the the the villain from
the movie
gorzo gorza he he is the big one you
should be looking out for different pair
of dogs is this like the beverly hills
cough game where they didn't have
license to like the actual story no
that's just the title and the logo
what's so crazy about the ghostbusters
game is that it's actually good it's
actually a decent representation other
than the fact that the f.1 is like the
worst car in the game which is stupid
but i mean it's you're what you're
seeing on the screen you're driving
around doing all this stuff you're
driving the extra one there it is you
got to do this thing it's in kilometers
so you're right at home well not anymore
well not anymore no you're just like
gone full convert yet no we know we were
maznero and then europe got involved
yeah
europe jerks what are you gonna do but
no yeah i mean you wanted a game that
like defined me i would not be here
without ghostbusters the video game it
saved your life it did uh well no you've
got multiple versions i do want to see
the wait is this actually
signed by david craig it is i have my uh
my atari cartridge signed by david crane
the programmer on ghostbusters the
creator of a pitfall right yeah well
that his lesser-known game he's more
known for ghostbusters of course but no
so the story goes like this all right is
that i was uh believe it or not a
ghostbusters fan growing up it's what
it's my first piece of real
fandom outside of comic books i needed
to grow up and get a little bit outside
of the comic book so i went into the
ghostbusters of course they're
scientists yeah that's a natural step in
the evolution mortgages right yeah and
so obsessed with ghostbusters bottle my
mom bought me all the toys but mom and
dad bought it twice so one day they made
the mistake of taking me to toys r us
okay and they went down the video game
aisle and i did not know what a video
game was at this point i'm
pre-kindergarten at this this day and
age and i'm walking walking walking
behind the glass you remember the old
toys r us they got the the cartridge and
then they got to take a look out in
front i got a ticket yeah and i was
walking i'll put it here i'll do the
fact i was like
and then i got a corner of my eye i see
the ghostbusters logo and it's like and
i'm just finger to the glass and i'm
like that's what i want for my birthday
my mom and my mom's like that is a video
game and i'm like what is that and then
we had like a 10 minute conversation
there about what constituted the video
game did you have to get the console in
and everything oh yeah nice oh yeah yeah
that was the thing they broke up the
gifts because they were smart like uncle
mike i believe got me the game mom and
dad got me the console for their
knock-off duck hunt that came with it
and so yeah like that was like if it
wasn't for my love of ghostbusters who
knows when i would have got into video
games yeah i could have been athletic
and into sports and god forbid that
anything could happen you could have
walked by there's a ghostbusters branded
baseball bat
yeah it's like a ghostbusters branded
pole
stripper like
just anything i like how you thought you
were going fisherman with that danny i'm
not gonna lie i like how you all jumped
to me being the thing i i saw a video
game i don't make the games be i'd be
reviewing strippers all right you're
writing about baseball
that's how it would work
imagination got carried away that was a
stirring origin story yeah right that
was great and so yeah years later david
crane was in the office and they're like
oh we need your interview i'm like great
and i went through his page i'm like
who's this old guy pitfall sucks and i'm
looking through and i found out that he
made the ghostbusters game so i had this
cartridge for the atari version from one
and only craig harris
i ran and so i saved up my pocket this
is a great moment that you can catch on
ign.com right now
where i allow it
it's probably easier to go youtube david
crane anyways uh
i i he sat down and we're sitting there
talking and i i did that whole story i
just told you i'm like by the way you
created me and i told the whole story
and then i whipped out the cartridge and
had him sign it and he he didn't seem as
impressed with it as i hoped oh really i
thought he'd be like oh man i thought
you were somebody i'm an idiot but no
you're just like
okay all right let's go full circle
connect it back up oh i also brought
ghost house as an honorable mention
because everybody loved the story of
mick
tell us
i don't know i never you don't know
ghost house i've never seen a single
card
what is the sega card this is how ahead
of the time the sega master system was
it accepted two forms of media two you
could either use the big fat cartridge
or you could be the happening kid with
the credit card looking card and just be
like
right here
sorry we don't take american express sir
well do you take the sega card and then
you put it in and they'd be like no
that's still not
what you're doing there you go i'll read
you a little bit about ghost house
though because this is even this is even
worse than the ghostbusters one at some
point uh but you've basically your name
mick you've been left a house you have
to go through and get even left a
haunted house the bad news is that
they're hidden inside count dracula's
mansion they have been for years first
you have to wipe out the bats dracula's
and eventually they're annoying annoying
henchmen
it's count dracula's mansion and you
just said he was a singular dracula and
now there's dracula's but even worse is
it a lowercase d at least no it's still
uppercase and then eventually they're
annoying henchmen like the annoying
henchmen are worse than the multiple
draculas
the worst of heiress
the worst vampire in the history of
vampires there are multiple but man the
annoying henchmen that's what really
gets done oh there's a dracula you just
punch them in the gut and then the best
is they do a pun here at the very end
ghoul luck
how big is this like 10 kilobytes or
something
because it's like
15 i don't know you could fit a jpeg on
that right exactly
thank you so much for bringing that
museum because it makes us feel a lot
better about having you this xbox 360.
yes well that was the thing i had asked
you if you had a master system you're
like we can dig one out i was like i was
all set to order a new master system and
by new i just mean order matches all
right so i haven't played ghostbusters
in forever okay 25 years so you better
complete it the big thing about here
okay here we go
oh wait what
there we go my name is g
j oh well good enough all right
count it count it throw a v in there i
don't know
money welcome to the business world
see now here's the thing about it is
everybody thought this was a
ghostbusters game
david crane he said it was a business
simulator because you have to go through
and decide how you spend your money then
buy stuff then go out see the sports car
it's you wanted the sports car danny of
course because you wanted to get there
as fast as possible you have to go on
calls here okay this isn't you just get
in there and you're a successful
ghostbusters you gotta bust your buns to
make sure you're the best ghostbuster
but of course everybody wants the extra
one yeah i'll buy that for right now
it's like the cheapest one with a lot of
them right now you gotta go through and
you gotta buy like look at this this is
a lot more than you thought there'd be
wait wait why do you have a
cherry or a forklift you gotta kid it
out these things are you know on top of
not knowing the ghostbusters i think
that yeah they didn't watch the movie to
be like oh well this is what we gotta do
here these things must be huge okay all
right so
yeah see now here's the thing people
forget about the ghostbusters game right
is that yeah hold on put this in the car
sorry uh you go through it right you're
doing all this the whole point was you
aren't we this is i don't don't get ah i
don't want to steal anything from here
this is the first dark souls this is the
first demon souls of games because
you're you're going to lose your first
round because what you do is you lose
then you get an account number you enter
it in next time you play you come back
with more money you're kidding you start
with more money so you can keep buying
off it's got a new game plus or first
game plus the only game plus
yeah watermelons
and this was of course the big thing to
me as a kid of just being like
first off i don't want to drive the
sports car i got to drive the sports car
yeah secondly
none of this crap looks like the
ghostbusters crap yeah you're a super
anion beam is that even in the thing no
okay oh god no you can't fit that in
yeah i don't have money i'm bad at math
everybody i didn't go by and see a math
video game all right
uh
defensively
yeah
we're gonna get our ass handed to us why
am i even trying super good thank you
what's the ghost base oh that's how you
get the you'll see i'll bring it on you
because we have to go out on the streets
and trap these guys we gotta also scare
off the go you'll see
there's a lot going on i had a version
of this money for the apple 2gs this
game made on like everything i think was
broken okay either that or i was just
terrible at it i literally could not
succeed in any endeavor now again greg
miller has not played ghostbusters in a
long time and the d-pad doesn't work
just the analog stick
go up ghostbuster
just go get this baby beluga ghostbuster
in the corner yeah ghost in the corner
are you doing a vehicular homicide on
that pedestrian oh i got to get to the
red thing that's right that's where the
ghost is oh now we get to go out now we
got to drive okay we're going to this
call you're doing 44 was just mapping
your gps right yeah what was yeah what
exactly was that just prefigured that
technology by about a decade is this
part of the game or loading i'm in
control
wow now again an accurate representation
of the streets of new york gruesome
trauma on the streets of new york all
right so we got to go here if i remember
i don't know what the one and two
buttons are but there there should be a
way to toss uh oh i bet i don't have the
money for it because eventually you can
bust the ghosts that are coming at you
okay so here we go now like a drive-by
busting right uh we are too late see
isn't this game fun kid oh my god
the original demon soul
now you see what's gonna happen is i
can't let these
guys get to zuul because i can make zuul
there we go i put down the ghost bait
and now i just found my buttons to do a
track and b apparently is what's what's
the button okay okay and then you gotta
kill here nailed it press all of them
all right there we go yeah go here we go
all right now we're back in the road all
right there's gonna be a ghost here
unless i get in another fatal car
accident uh i kind of oh
all right here we go you're burning
through staff at the moment
oh man that's how that's how it gets one
if we make it to the final thing where
you've got to fight stay positive it's
actually all just a parable against
drunk driving as these people swerve
wildly back and forth how are they doing
what's going on i don't have any of the
stuff to bust them with oh yeah i do
oh that's the vacuum okay oh nice yeah
you got your super what are you doing
right over here i mean okay here we go
slimers all right i'm gonna put her oh
that is a lot of slimers are you here
and i move you here no was that great
now yeah and then we do we walk together
oh anything you gotta make him into
don't cross the street make him into a
call did you write the back of the box
yeah okay so you do that and then okay
oh nice nails
got it ladies and gentlemen
the original dark souls
go to the little bit all right here we
go
now we're back in the car
uh how many times give us a little
insight into how you feel right now do
you feel you're good i'm feeling really
good you are busted my only problem is i
cannot well come on that was a little
bit of light purple are the ghosts
they're still right there let me get the
ghost are they ever in the not out on
the street
no no inside your hands
this is this is like you ever see gangs
of new york
they're pulling from that continuity
where people only died in the streets
right
you get there
oh he's dead slime to death he died on
the job and you know what slime looks
like all fun and games but until it
floods your lungs and you asphyxiate see
if i'm oh that's and if i touch them oh
god go ah i can't get up kick it up i
blame the xbox controller as always
what are these oh you got to like tap
them
to freeze them because if they if enough
get into the zuul that starts the end
game that's happening no matter what
then of course you got keymaster but
you're trying to like get some more
money right so you can go to the shop
there gear up some more
so that you're prepared to take on the
king of all ghosts how would you how how
long does it take to complete this bad
boy if you like had a real fight you
knew what i was doing yeah i don't know
i was a damn kid i don't know do you
have no empty traps you got to go back
to ghostbusters hq
i don't know i have no traps how'd you
see i read it at the top of the screen
have you ever completed this yeah oh you
have oh yeah okay it's at the end you
have to like well i didn't do it as a
kid when i first made it i could never
get up god damn it wow that was [ __ ]
new york driving she's louise sir
i can stop texting i can see why they
call it mad men
oh god see amc's mad man no set new or
no
two girls two broke girls
yeah stay on message here
i think i'm getting better at driving if
i got 20 kilometers to go next i don't
think new york is this big i don't think
you're going that fast either and i was
right in front of the ghostbusters hq
and this is actually in westchester
county they have to save some money
you're pretty driving at a kilometer
second true story this is a one-for-one
recreation of streets in new york it's
the first open world game yeah yeah oh
you're getting new stuff because you've
murdered all your
why is this pixel perfect
how many of them have to get in before a
bunch of that pke energy stuff up there
i think it matters is there any points
of the people walking around yeah
they're just there's that rick moran
exactly
it's keymaster they're walking around
gatekeeper and keymaster
eventually they go to zul2 that's when
this thing gets real man
you can do it
come on there we go come on oh yeah
robin is racing am i right guys
dear god hey this came in 84. i believe
it was an atari game first yeah and then
this was a porsche then i got ported
over to the plugins in this one i love
how the box was just literally the logo
that was the cash
man of the ghostbusters back in the day
that's what you needed all right so i'll
put the one there
and who am i controlling trolling you
vankman
spit roasted by ghosts the worst way to
go
uh we're nearly about time for this if
you want to get those guys to
all right
okay i think if i let them go they they
they power up zuul is that right
everybody somebody remember that i think
sure yeah
yeah why not whatever does the meter
keeps going yeah the pka meters filling
in pk energy meter
can we just talk about what a brilliant
game this was
like i've given a bad impression of not
being able to go right and left that's
pretty it's pretty good it's a game that
came out in 1994. don't block them oh
i'm still getting zoomed i'm sorry i was
that's like you're you're just i was
impressed that i could finally turn
really i'll see you right there i can't
turn the whole city is popping off right
now oh no the
oh what the hell
oh you got it oh now it's gotta get red
man we're like oh
what no yeah no it's just a puff i
forgot get him no he's i'm frozen right
now marshmallow alert wow he just
destroyed an entire city block while you
stood by and watched well it would have
taken me four years to listen there i'm
i'm pretty sure that this game claims
you can you get to get closer than
anyone's ever been to the ominous
marshmallow man oh you haven't seen it
if you were like four city blocks as
long as this game doesn't end with us
just failing in the city destroyed which
i'm not sure if it's a possibility
because i was so good as a kid
you're going to get closer to this
marshmallow than you ever have before
oh he's just murdering everyone he's so
cute this is awful
have you seen godzilla no not yet
so good i was out of town last weekend i
really liked it yeah bobby it's
polarizing they're saying yeah and they
i mean me talking to people yeah yep uh
i don't know you go into it expecting a
monster movie you're gonna get a fun
monster movie okay that's all i want you
know you know i'm saying it's not the
the cutting cultural commentary that
people have been looking for in their
monster movies
uh no i would say that is not the case
we're nearly there there we go we got no
bars nearly full if that changes
business
this meter changes purple yeah i know
wow yeah yeah
is a smoking ruin
i think ghostbusters may be the most
popular game on the stream today
because it's the best wolfenstein's
coming up but that's not the best based
on the best property of all time this is
it here we go now i if i'm right they
yeah see look at the gatekeeper
keymaster they're making a run for it
now we get to go if i can make it past
uh shakespeare not shakespeare
sustainable oh no i screwed it up all
together
well
there you go gorza gorzo indeed
awakening
you couldn't even set foot inside it
because you're unable to earn enough
money to gain admittance like right what
is that even you got to gain money so
you can gain admittance to fight the go
to save the city
the game is over try again from the
start that's cannon from the movie you
remember because if you you didn't have
enough money earned by the end of
ghostbusters yeah you had to tip the
bell man yeah you can't grease his
pockets
he knows mankind isn't he's a high class
establishment exactly please
unbelievable greg miller thank you very
much for coming in and showing the scope
for me stick around we're going to play
some wolfenstein want to come in and
have a have a chat about that yeah yeah
all right well we'll be back in a second
after some words from our sponsors
were you really on the air if you had
enough yeah yeah i was tweeting follow
me on game over greg yeah gamer over
greggy go to ign don't leave a third for
that
probably not probably not it just shows
thai roots it just shows ty ruth's lower
third ah look at that it's me
i don't know how to eat stuff
you gotta work on your eating uh what
would i be doing if i had see here's the
thing about me
like i said obsessed with ghostbusters
but the first obsession was superman
okay and so you would have been super
bad can you unplug them what i think i
would have been is what because i was
talking about this is that i think i
based most of my life choices on
just attaching myself to the superman
lore in the beginning right knew i
wanted to wear nerd glasses from the
start really knew i wanted to be a
journalist i have a degree in journalism
that's eventually how i knew i'd get
into video games writing about games and
stuff now you might say greg you're
overweight superman isn't overweight but
i would not say that
yeah yeah
the thing about it superman doesn't have
to work out right superman well first
off he's working out when he's pushing
stuff around but you remember of course
in the canon adventure lois and clark's
the new adventures of superman dean kane
looked like dean cain and he just had
covers filled with cookies that's all he
ate so i think i based my decisions on
that as well and there you go
so i think it all works out so if i was
it's
you're not you know you didn't get to
right it's always somebody else's fault
and i'll look like this ripley's believe
it or not right
ripley's blame it on someone else
deep deep deep cut on dean imdb page
right there i love it
but yeah i'd probably be if i wasn't uh
hanging out talking about games i'd
probably still be a journalist somewhere
yeah i bet i would have kept going that
way well what else what else do you
think in terms of like maybe media
would it have been sports would have
been current events do you think like
you know comic books obviously yeah that
would have been a good one i think
probably if for some reason video games
never come around i loved wizard
magazine so reading that and seeing how
much fun those guys were having probably
been a good one i always thought about
that too you know
ign.com does a bunch of different things
right and the one i've always loved the
comic side of our site where i'm just
like man i would have i
in a different world i would have loved
to have written for that and done that
and done comic based content for the
channel who knows the future yeah this
these video games aren't gonna make it i
know totally look at this they're just
remaking old ones we're looking at
wolfenstein new order here
uh which is a great collaboration
between a fantastic english uh rock band
and uh your favorite nazi killing um
simulator chris waters you've been
playing a bunch of this yes uh give me
the elevator pitch how good is this
video game this could have gone either
way that's really good yeah it's really
fun it's just like a great fun shooter
business you get to knife a nazi oh i
missed it that's all right i get another
shot he's not super alert oh crap oh now
who's super
bad situation all right oh stealth out
the window anyway oh no there's nothing
look at the nazi robot dogs they have
right this one's this one's only
semi-robotic
oh what what are you doing on the ground
the dog knocked him over oh god whoa
that guy just go that was weird
uh he went over here crap video games
are having a lot of guns and what are
you playing this on uh this is on the
xbox one it looks really pretty it is a
very good looking game
i'm playing it on a difficulty level
that is four out of five difficulties on
the difficulties uber the hardest
difficulty yes so this is not uber i
need to
i just okay if you have any questions at
all about what we'll sign the new order
uh
no twitch gamespot comments or at
gamespot on the twitters from what i
played i'm a big fan of wolfenstein so
far yeah so how do you how would you
place it on on you know like compared to
like a
a modern shooter right i mean it's
certainly more in the
call of duty vein in terms of your
mobility it's not it's not a titanfall
it's not a halo uh it's in terms of the
gun play you know
i think crank i've been playing it on
uber difficulty for the most part and
cranking up the difficulty does make it
significantly harder you'll see like i
got overwhelmed there i had to stay
behind cover just to stay alive uh and
then dudes were all over me so it kind
of it it wants to hark back to that old
school
feel right i mean for me i'm playing it
on normal because i'm a wuss and i do
love the fact that when i started to
move the difficulty around it
immediately started insulting me like
it shows like him as a baby or them is
covered in blood
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like for me it's
the video game equivalent to like you
know the blockbuster movie right it's a
popcorn movie like it's over the top
you're in a coma for 14 years and you
snap out of it and start stabbing nazis
and breaking their necks and it's like
yeah he has these ridiculous lines of
ridiculous enemies you can throw a knife
and if you actually hit somebody it's a
one-hit kill i know what is with my
terrible knife as you go like there's
these amazing kills like that like it's
just it's a fun like stupid in quote
game i'm getting a kind of a bullet
stormy vibe off in that respect that
it's kind of like it's not taking itself
seriously yeah that's the big part of it
right so the idea is like these guys oh
god yeah i've got this sick laser gun
that's kind of upgraded it actually has
this like auto targeting thing now sure
it does but it takes a lot of energy so
you got to go to these energy charts
stations to recharge it oh it's half
life i got it that broadcasting alarm
thing is a problem for me because it's
just going to call reinforcements the
whole time
while he does that and is there a set
number of dudes or is it just going to
monster closet these guys until really
no because usually i take care to kill
the commanders before they can broadcast
the alarm have you found the uh the
story stuff so far chris uh so yeah
that's that's been an interesting part
of it considering story is not something
people really consider you know a heavy
part of the nostalgia trip wolfenstein
it's a lot better i mean obviously it's
it there is a story there is uh bj
blaskowitz is a character like you know
he is sure he's the like beat the crap
out of nazis character but uh she's not
using my rockets here but he's also
like he kind of
recognizes the horrors of war and has
this like ragtag group of resistance
fighters that are also characters in
their own right that you get to get to
come to know and uh die horribly and
talking about video games while i'm
talking about it
it's always difficult uh i like it
because it also does this thing that
where it has um
you know you'll go from sort of
stealthing sections which i've just
basically finished at this point i'm in
the middle of i'm like halfway this is
at this point is about
two third halfway or two thirds through
the game how long have you been playing
for
uh
does it feel long enough i don't know it
that does feel substantial because of
course there's no multiplayer component
on this correct
uh it feels substantially long and it
also has these moments that where you
are like in the hideout with the
resistance fighters like talking to them
about stuff like exploring the
the area to like find them some thing
they need to help out all right let's do
something different here
i'm gonna go with the silenced handgun
instead of the knife throw because the
knife throw i have been uh not i really
just hate that crate youtube keep trying
to kill oh hello friend hello he was
looking right at you he's gonna regret
that
i think i'm gonna regret that yeah they
know because they are yelling your
pistol made no noise but his head
exploding made a load of noise that is
not a gun
not in gun mode he has a swastika on his
like collar
yeah like his name is swastika
they wanted to make sure you didn't
if you run into a cybernetic dog on the
street you need to know at a glance if
it's a nazi you're a jew and so they're
like the nazis are like we're going to
pretty quickly put it right yeah we're
going to make sure it's one of those
it's one of our dogs
you a jewish dog oh you're one of our
robot evil dogs all right so come with
me you've also got regenerating here
like you saw was down to uh
i was down to three health there i went
back up to 20.
oh i'm at 13. i'm going to go back up to
20. you regenerate to increments of 20.
so it's like a neat little straddling of
the regenerating health paradox that has
never really been solved yeah for better
or worse has you know
taken a a huge role in modern shooters
the a huge sort of contentious role and
this brings back the old-school
overcharge mode too where if you're at
100 you get an extra you go into gold
and you can have like 140 and then it
slowly starts counting down okay you did
that in this as well yes indeed awesome
all right i've got some questions coming
in here and neoburn 82 just some
technical ones first i heard the weapon
switching isn't that great is that true
this is the weapon switching it's on the
wheel you kind of got a point to it i
would say it's you know it's a
it takes a little bit of getting used to
to be able to do it in the heat of
combat you saw me earlier like switching
to accidentally to my laser gun but it's
actually in cutting mode and not in fry
and nazi mode can you just hot switch
between two different i can so i can
boom okay see your previous hello friend
i heard something oh my god it's a guy
with two machine guns
eminem stranger on twitch asks does
stealth have good ai for enemies this is
a constant worry on first-person games
uh no this it's not like you know
it's not even something as complicated
as dishonored where they're gonna be in
different sort of states of
investigating you and you have to like
double evade them when they're a little
bit alerted they're either alerted or
they're not so if you're creeping into a
base in one of those levels and you trip
a switch
that's it game over you are going to be
shooting those dudes like out in the
open for the rest of the section
absolutely and uh yeah you're gonna all
right this is it i'm gonna be meeting a
friend here in a second so i'm gonna try
to find some more health which you can
find in some of these crates uh these
anything that has metal that looks like
this can be cut open oh that's great and
so like hopefully there's some armor or
something wait a second has the new
wolfenstein just actually reinvented
crates
is this the game that did us reinvent
gave us a new mechanic in relation to
craig you can cut them open oh my gosh
uh yeah there starts you off on ones you
can just break yeah but then it does it
goes next gen and gives you the crate
yeah like here's one that you can just
knife there you go all right
they don't want to they don't want to
lose people they want you know the young
animal to be able to get attached to
this crate business i don't like these
new crates in this video game it's not
when like when i was a kid all right can
you still eat plates of chicken for
can you i haven't found any place of
chicken but you know how they have these
dogs which you can just take the armor
off of them and put them on put it on
yourself of course
you can eat bowls of nazi dog food right
really yeah wow like they when you come
across dog food and you just like chomp
it down plus four health sell processing
on twitch ask can you step through the
entire game no you cannot for example
that guy hey can you steal nazi gold
like in wolf inside 3d that's what he
did yeah there's lots of nuts
so uh that was easy that was easy
because
nazis suck you don't actually get the
this attachment for this weapon until a
couple levels from now okay so i'm
making it look a little easier than it
actually is but like i can grab this
dude's metal and just like
i just like love this image of like yeah
he's just like duct tape
all those random metals wearing a stack
of eight nazi hats like but moving
perfectly stealthy yeah no problem uh
how how how much of this game have you
spent rubbing up against walls and
smashing a space bar zero
uh is there one picture of hitler
i haven't there's like a blurry one that
kind of looks like him but they don't
really talk about hitler a lot like
death's head is the chief antagonist and
you meet him
early did you meet him in your playtime
how was that meeting awesome it was so
awesome right yeah i mean like it's so
creepy the game does stuff that it has
no business doing it's it has no
business being as much fun as it is both
in cut scene form and gameplay form
because it's just like you're running
around blowing stuff up fighting these
crazy ass enemies like you were talking
about nazis just putting nazi symbols on
everything it's like god i hate you guys
more than ever
yep that's what they do uh but yeah man
it's
it's got like i've said this before when
we've sort of had it on stream and stuff
the villains have character
uh and that just makes it so much more
satisfying and they make you hate them
yes i mean on top of all the horrible
things nazis do yeah but on top of that
they do even more if you needed a reason
right yeah
they make it much more
yeah make them great antagonists and now
this is gonna
you know even if i'd still through this
stuff i would have had to fight the
monster
right here
uh now there's like there's a ton more
nazis coming my way uh all right i'm
gonna ask you both a question i'm gonna
ask greg first sure uh this is a game
that has a first person game associated
with pc uh
there's this long conversation about
multiplayer in relation to first person
games generally so there is a kind of an
omission in relation to this linear
first person shooter game that does not
have multiplayer do you think that that
is a problem that
is just made up of forum posts and
message boards and doesn't should not
really exist that it's like unreasonable
to expect every game to have multiplayer
or do you feel like this is less of a
package because it doesn't have that i
think it's 100 uh made-up thing i mean
it's it's back to just
you know line items on the back of a box
right i underst it's video games cost a
lot of money and everybody understands
this they want you to feel like you're
getting a lot for your money but how
many games have you played where you
never touched the multiplayer mode tomb
raider or you touch the multiplayer mode
it's just garbage you know what i mean
i'd rather see 120 of these guys be like
hey because it works we're making this
fun game that's a popcorn movie that's
totally over the top and goofy let's
focus on that and make that the best it
can be and not worry about shoehorning
in it or going you know giving some
other developer you make the multiplayer
for us and we'll try to piece them
together and you'll get coins that carry
over no like don't even worry about it
you know what i mean like i think
developers should be allowed to have a
vision and go out and create it and not
have to be bogged down with well crap
now we need this cool i think there's a
salient example that also uses the tech
5 engine which is rage i mean that game
was a real bulky single player shooter
and then the multiplayer mode was like a
demolition derby in cars and it was
totally
uninteresting it was totally tacked on
like not not an interesting way to spend
time and yeah it it had it it checked
the box for multiplayer but
did anyone like really enjoy that a
bunch i don't think so i mean i
certainly didn't and oh god
just died
yeah so these are ricochet shells sure
are i can tell he died
because there's his gun did your
friendly fire turned off can you hurt
yourself uh no you cannot hurt yourself
come on b.j blaskowitz hurt himself no
way ever
uh yeah so i think that you know there's
the great thing about the game industry
that we continue to see year to year
despite the you know avalanche of
sequels and uh
games that seem the same as other games
is the is new niches being filled new
niche is being created and i think that
the single player uh first person
shooter
that's some hot level oh there was
somebody up there who followed me up
there all right so there's another way
to finish this which i'll just do now
well i can expedite this uh as long as
you want i think there's
the niche of single player only first
person shooter got lost in the avalanche
of like
you know
now consoles can go online now console
online multiplayer is the hot thing like
it's gotta have multiplayer especially
if you're shooting something that's a
naturally competitive endeavor you want
to shoot someone else in the face it's
human nature uh in a virtual setting
absolutely uh but you know it's uh
i think that it's great to have games
like this and i think that this game you
know it's sort of it shows in the care
that this campaign has in the stuff you
like you were mentioning earlier
it it feels like it has no business
doing it but of course it should do this
stuff of course the shooter campaign
should like have character should have
uh you know should be challenging should
have a lot of environments and weapons
and all this stuff and when i go back
and think about some of like the best
first person shooters i've played on
consoles specifically over the past
generation like it's games like like
portal and bioshock infinite which
didn't get much better until the dlc i
believe um or bioshock
to it oh yeah um
and then on bethesda's side i guess
they're they're no strangers to making
incredible single-payer campaigns sure
single-payer games with uh with with the
elder scrolls and fallout series so like
we had pete hines on the show um
at pax at our
live lobby and like he put forward that
idea that like it is
increasingly difficult to try and create
games that take both areas like you
always sacrifice something and doing one
when you're doing the other um so yeah
i'm kind of interested to
you know especially when you're trying
to make something this caliber and that
kind of budget that's involved in in
just making a single-player gaming
campaign this is expensive man the
licensing for swastikas is like insane
and you know who talked about that a lot
was uh vince ampella and respawn those
guys were talking about making titanfall
multiplayer only shooter yeah like valid
points about the the investment versus
the sort of player time that you get out
of a single player campaign in a
multi-player focus shooter i feel like
this is the week where it's getting
super exciting in terms of new releases
for these consoles we're getting this
we've transistor
watchdogs is out next week i believe
yeah um and then we're straight into e3
and it's going to be a whole bunch of
mess about what's coming up for the next
one uh have you felt like it's kind of
simmered down a bit over since uh yeah
yeah i mean when the i mean when we
brought the boxes home right it was the
excitement of having it and then the uh
i guess i'll play lego marvel again like
you know what i mean like there wasn't
those driving forces and that's why you
had titanfall and second sun out is like
those are all the lighthouses we're
going towards those ones we can't wait
to then we got those got lost knows and
then on the other side it's been that
what next and i'm sure i mean like for
wolfenstein i'm sure that's going to
work to its favor right the fact that
you know it's a game that everybody
loves and so business being this good
and that's kind of a backhanded insult
right but it's like people are here and
they're like okay great i'm totally in
for something different and something
cool and something goofy to go play with
what do you think about the perception
that so as a consumer buying a a shooter
you exp like if it's got multiplayer
then you kind of think like oh well if
it's got multiplayer then if well if
it's going to have a lot of multiplayer
and i'm not really going to want to play
the multiplayer then it is is it a bad
value proposition for me to buy the game
right like am i is it not going to be
worth it because because i'm not a huge
multiplayer fan i'm not going to be
taking advantage of this significant
portion of the game
i definitely think that's something on
people's mind you know i mean i think
that's why they're promoting it the way
they're promoting it they're promoting
it on the strength of the brand
wolfenstein the name wolfenstein this
one means a lot to a lot of gamers you
know i mean especially now with
everybody having these consoles or you
know the fervor around them i think the
fact that they're coming out and doing
that and making it all about bj blasquez
and the campaigns and maybe showing him
with that gigantic chainsaw right
they know what they're doing
oh crap oh no
i think that sums up the uh experience
of uh playing wolfenstein uber soldier
that uber soldier chris waters thank you
very much for playing some of this mess
with us my pleasure i was glad i was
able to succeed to some degree thanks
being titanfall earlier as well yeah we
are we are giving this game away though
we are giving this game away in fact we
have to give it away right now so this
is the uh the the panzer hunt
pack which involves has all this
paraphernalia surrounding the game
including this awesome nazi robot dog
figurine a bunch of uh concept art and
uh other bits and bobs for all you
wolfenstein fans or fans of nazis i
don't know
i'm just going to say that you see
anything do you think there's a section
behind it because of that maybe maybe do
you think that this game is really
popular in like
i don't want to go there do you think
that they what the south do you think
that they they
they oh my gosh this finally makes sense
then they'll make a special edition
without the game because nazi fans just
want the nazi stuff but they don't want
to shoot nazis
the jig is not pete hines it took the
power of ign and gamespot collaborating
figuring
but then i went back and then it was
just us being nerds
we have the winner and as our guest uh
mr greg miller i believe you should uh
you should be the one the winner on
twitter is at vancey
i met fancy at pax east he did yeah she
we talked about final fantasy and my
review for lightning returns
congratulations that's awesome nice work
that'll be in a
packaged box to you super soon you'll
know which one it is it's the [ __ ]
huge square
make sure you let us know what uh what
console you want to uh you want that on
as well or pc xbox one ps4 or pc yes
thank you very much great rumor i heard
a rumor on game spot it's coming to ps3
and 360. no no didn't that didn't panic
like it's just sticking ghostbusters
back up there oh this is the end of
ghostbusters oh really you have to go up
so many goddamn flights of stairs it's
like
that as a kid that's what i couldn't do
because there's these god damn ghosts up
there that are throwing plates at you
yeah it's like just get out of my face
dead hotel worker i don't get into the
top of this thing then you get up here
yeah and this is the big fight this is
where it becomes a shmup yeah exactly
now let's fight gorza gorza who knows
how to strafe there's an exploit too i
don't yeah look at that you have to
dance there's an exploit that if you
went up to one of the terror dogs and
chilled out for a second you could walk
over and then just destroy gorzo but
this guy didn't even need it wait did
the tesla get even
netflix now
enjoy it greg miller thank you very much
for coming on thanks for having
this week oh doctor a whole bunch of
stuff what's on up noon this week up at
noon is coming up this week uh well
we're filming it this week and then it
goes live on monday every ign.com noon
every monday uh up at noon it's going to
be great we've got a little bunny ears
camera we're going to talk about our
mobile games killing console games with
a guy who made a mobile game in his now
this isn't up at noon at all this is the
other show i do the game over gregory
show
look at that that is a good looking shot
well it's over now here comes up at noon
well this is this is the stick with it
it's going to open in a second there it
is oh my goodness it's multiplying now
this start thing doesn't exist anymore
but the ign thing does and then up at
noon is this comedy thing holy crap is
this an old episode
that's nick scarpino holy geez
and here's where we're talking about hot
girls and why our show isn't popular
because it has fat dudes on it
you guys really knew the clips to pick i
was wondering why why we were having
trouble with the lobby as well
yeah well yeah yeah but then the
team fat they they support us they come
together p-h-a-t no no no just f-a-t all
right that's coming up on next week's
episode uh we're gonna talk about talk
to a mobile developer joining up for
that uh
suit no it's not a flappy cat can you
imagine what the flappy that'd be a show
i'd watch this one not so much
up a new every monday ign.com
awesome thanks very much oh my god
thanks so much for having us yeah we
should get you one again uh to play some
more uh old whips like sure well we
didn't play ghost house so that's always
in the car still on the menu still on
there
to download the romp for it's probably
just three kilobytes that's a game i
never beat oh really that one
there's so many there's so many evil
henchmen in dracula so many draculas how
can you how can one man overcome so many
dracula it's about a four-hour
livestream coming up endurance run yeah
yeah all right thanks everyone for
checking us out this week uh thanks for
uh
going in trying to get win that awesome
wolfenstein thing with not the game but
then we gave you the game with you uh
congratulations to everyone who won that
one person but there's one more
competition coming we're giving away a
ps4 with watchdogs on gamespot.com
that's gamespot.com forward slash ps4
giveaway it ends 5 5 30. i think that
means the may 30th may 30th you got
american you've got the weird that's the
we do it the right way that's really
strange and i believe that's thursday
week i think and then it's hella e3
video games are happening go home play
transistor and wolfenstein we'll talk to
you guys next week thanks very much
dudes yeah buddy we
have let's try it again
nailed it oh then we do that too yeah
you